hello and welcome to the new world
review where we are going to whoa
look out behind you no really not be
careful you don't want it to sneak up
behind you
check that out here we see the subscribe
button in its native environment
it looks red and it's looking directly
at you how you ask do you make it stop
staring at you well dear friend the best
way to stop it is to click it and it
will face away from you and you will see
its grey behind pointing delicately in
your direction
okay but enough of that foolishness why
don't we talk about hunter hunter
because that's why i'm here that's why
you're watching and you can already see
bountiful beautiful button behinds
anyway
episode 54 ah yes the creepy laughter of
children
exactly what we want in our day-to-day
world this episode seems to be setting
us up for the next arc which i suspect
is going to take place in meteor city
the land of opportunity
and non-existence yay back to chrollo's
childhood which tells us
something we've heard about meteor city
before canary hails from that region
we knew that the phantom troop came from
there because she told kilwa about it
way back when
i'll be honest the idea of getting out
of normal cities with huge numbers of
iphones to a literal dump is quite
appealing even if everyone there is
still mafia there's something i keep
touching on which is the emotional
connection between the members of the
phantom troop and
i'd like to touch on it a little more
here it tells us a lot about crollo
knowing he was raised in that dump it's
your typical rags to riches tale of a
man who decided to fagin his way to
glory
except with the addition of really
dangerous abilities that make them all
ludicrously sociopathic to everyone
outside of their group the fact that
he's willing to leave
uvogin and take the rest of them home
rather than pushing his luck and
potentially losing more of them shows
that the fortunes they received
in which they're all mourning the loss
of a member is more than just
words the phantom troop actually are
mourning and their behavior was in fact
a response to that morning
it doesn't make it good or right but it
gives them a level of humanity that i've
been seeing but not
fully connecting with to now in the same
way that gone
going home and spending time on the
beach with kilowatt discussing how much
he cares for mito humanized him
seeing that crolo collected his group of
people from all over but that they were
likely all outcasts that banded together
to form a strange sort of family
humanizes them they're monsters sure but
monsters in the same way that gone and
quilo are monsters and broken in the
same way that korapic has broken
the central tension of this series seems
to be the effect of revenge on people
who could otherwise be good people and
it would be interesting to see what
could have happened to krollo if he'd
had a different lie
in that way it's particularly important
to notice that once he had
neon's power he could have killed her
but chose not to
and by the same token he chose not to
kill or try to kill the zoldicks that
second point might be more because
they're an important part of the
ecosystem of evil
evil system if you will
but still where he can avoid it he
doesn't kill and nor do any of the other
troop members
they're sort of a neutral evil they do
things for their own purposes and don't
kill unless they need to or unless
they're told to
they're effective war machines are
effective at doing what they want or
need to but they have enough restraint
to only do it if there is a distinct
benefit to the action
continuing the heartbreaking experience
of last episode kudarpica finally caught
up with his friends and they were all
finally back together for the first time
since the end of the main part of the
hunter exam
knowing what he would learn about the
existence of the phantom troupe
eventually
meant that the excitement and happiness
of the situation was incredibly tense as
a watching experience
because i spent the entire time trying
to figure out when krapika would learn
the timing of it when he just decided to
put down the revenge and seek out his
people made it all the more
heartbreaking
also kilbur made a very good point and
now korabika is in a serious amount of
danger because his friends know
information about him that compromises
him what they need to do now is make
sure they kill pakunoda first
get rid of her and the others will never
know that compromising information right
hey do we think her boobs are like armor
or something because i can't imagine how
well she keeps them
that still in her jacket sorry still
thinking about that
also will korapika accept their help now
that they're just going to give away his
secrets if they get caught again anyway
let's discuss these fortunes i'm not
going to run through
all of them this time i love a good
fortune and a bit of prophecy but it's
all about how the prophecy is
interpreted that makes for an
interesting time
in this particular case it's about how
they interpret their own prophecies that
makes for an interesting time the
response by some to their death is more
expected than others
some are clearly not afraid of dying and
others
[Music]
is blinded by the need for revenge
vacuum girl was just trying to
understand the situation
she didn't seem to care one way or the
other whether she died just
understanding the future
i suppose being really forgetful she
won't need to worry about it for long
anyway
hisoka's fortune changing why does he
have a nullifying ability
did handing it over change it because
the outcome is different now does he
know what the new version says
well they read it out loud is he about
to do something different what happens
now
what happens now i want to know let's
watch episode 55.
okay this was a largely static episode
of discussion and planning
as someone who plays a lot of tabletop
roleplay games this sort of episode is
really actually very important the
tension dropped soon after we opened it
up because we can't maintain the level
of tension that happened in the last few
episodes we need a break mentally and we
need time to re-engage with where the
story is
it's a really clever play by the writer
especially when you take into account
all the fortunes that we're told it puts
everyone into their mind rather than
their body so we're thinking about what
these fortunes could mean
rather than you know feeling tense
the second crawler got in the way of
nobunaga attacking hisoka i could tell
that what we were doing was a controlled
leech of energy and that's
actually fine by me as long as it
doesn't sustain as long as we don't stay
in this place of like it's great i'm
also hoping still and probably futilely
at this point that we leave york new and
go somewhere else somewhere with less
phones but i also doubt that it's
possible one group will lure the other
out of the city to a less observed less
dense area but i also really don't know
that one
either so hisoka's inflating kurapika's
abilities unless he can't tell them for
another reason
it doesn't feel like a lie but it also
must be mustn't it the schwing of death
has been shung in crawlow's direction
and i can't help but think
hisoka's cheating on gone at this point
arguably gone also has a schwing shung
in the direction of the entire phantom
troop hisoka has the ability
sorry i should go back and and yeah you
know what gone has a schwing
he has a swing we've seen his swing his
swing was with zephiel okay
that schwing you have to fulfill your
potential
that is a mini swing and just just to
make that clear
that's what a mini swing looks like so
gone's mini swing shung
in the same direction as his circus
swing anyway
let's move on hisoka has the ability to
tell fortunes i wonder whether he can
know what they are or if they shift
based on what he expects or if he's just
writing fortunes really quickly what we
know is that he's not
lying to them so he can't well what we
think we know is that he's not lying to
them
so he can't possibly have complete
control over the ability the same way
crollo doesn't it's a good point though
crawler mimics other people's abilities
does every person's ability work the
same way
they have different names for them to
what degree do they have the same effect
are they imagination based obviously for
conjurers it's by their creativity but
is that the same for everyone we're
being kept on top of what's happening
with melody and neon and being given
some insight into character
relationships which tells me we've got
some death in coming
huzzah either the maid is gonna die or
dogman who has the most adorable puppies
just saying yay puppies kilwa's desire
to have kurapika turn gone down was an
interesting choice i understand that
he wants gone to stick to his own plans
but it also points out something of note
killa doesn't see kurapika as a close
friend or someone over as much note as
gone that might seem obvious but by the
end of the episode they're all basically
signing up for the same fate signing up
to put karapika in danger i suppose so
there's
little direct danger to kilauea himself
that said
kurapika deciding to let gon decide
strategy is perhaps the most brazen and
possibly downright dangerous thing
that's happened in this art we've
noticed that gone
works on instinct we've noted that he
doesn't do strategy so much as
recklessness and yet
here is karapika saying hey you choose
how to handle this but i need a second
with people you haven't managed to deal
with in a group before
that's wild that said having said
earlier that the most important person
they have to get rid of
is pakunoda that's exactly who they're
going for so hey i managed to predict
something correctly for once
that's nice and speaks to my incredible
intelligence and fortune telling prowess
that was lyoreo the fact that kurapika's
chains are a way to force
zetsu would be really important if i
could remember what all these things did
okay let's see um zetsu is
the way to avoid being detected
detective satsu
stop your oh wait it stops your sweaty
aura from leaking
right okay okay okay so sweaty aura gone
right so forcing people to use their
zetsu wait forcing people to use
or shut down their zetsu one of the two
forces them to shut down their aura
it forces them to turn it off
and without nen you can't do anything
but stand there hopeless and helpless in
chains and be trapped
that sounds like it sucks quite a bit
and now kudarpica can choose when to
make his eyes scarlet but they have to
be scarlet in order for him to be a
specialist so he can't hide them from
pakunoda so that's him
deliberately revealing himself to them
and does that mean crollo could steal
his power how do people become members
of the spider clan could crollo steal
power from
kurapika given that krapik is only a
specialist when he has scarlet eyes like
if the scarlet eyes the way
are the scarlet eyes the way the way
forward
anyway how do people become members of
the spider clan
if crowley just says yes you are now in
the phantom troupe is that enough for
karapika's stolen power to be used
against anyone crawler desires
it was really nice to get a breakdown of
what all his chains actually do one of
the things i'd wondered until now was
whether they had any more specific
abilities and what they might be
it's very specific to each person
clearly but the idea that a conjurer
needs to be exceptionally creative to
make their powers do anything useful is
really really
interesting to me he couldn't make an
unbreakable chain we know that but it's
close if another phantom trophy decided
to try to break the chain
while it was around someone else would
that work from the outside i know it's a
chain but still
i also love that the chain jail is his
middle finger it's the ultimate
to the spiders as he catches them in his
own web wait he said he can use the
chain
jail only on phantom troop but
specifically said his eyes had to be
read for the judgment chain
does that mean his eyes don't need to be
scarlet for the chain jail can he hide
his abilities from
them that much all that well also let's
discuss
leorio and kilwa hiding while kurapika
told some really deep and dangerous
information that put him into further
danger
but like not actually leaving meaning
that the information that should have
been private was in fact not at all
private what is it with the lack of
privacy when there really should be i
mean
we can blame that on corapica for
failing to lower his voice but how can
you say
sure we're leaving because we're your
friends and we don't want to make things
worse then think yeah
we'll listen to it and decide what we
think after that silly kirapica and for
naboonaga
dude how do you forget the kids that got
away from you like that was your only
job you had one job that you gave
yourself
what were you even doing while everyone
else was away killing people and
stealing things from an auction
how do you forget that you had a couple
of teenage boys that actually managed to
get away from you
gone became the center of your world for
like a whole minute you don't deserve a
new hogan mark
ii you didn't take care of the first one
we can't trust you
maybe you can earn it back but next time
because that's it from me
if you enjoyed this hit subscribe check
out this link here and this one or
something here click a thing down here
there's a like button and a ding-a-ling
my ding-a-ling bye everyone oh
embarrassing